[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous vous regardez
l'échiquier mondial sur rt france au
sommaire aujourd'hui les tensions
croissantes dans le sud est asiatique et
en particulier en mer de chine
méridionale différends territoriaux
brouille autour de taiwan et de hong
kong sont autant de facteurs qui font de
cette partie du globe
un véritable champ de bataille
géopolitique comment tout cela affecte
la stabilité de la région en mer de
chine méridionale
la situation sécuritaire ne cesse de se
détériorer le 25 août un avion espion
américain traverse le golfe de bohai au
moment où pékin y mène des manoeuvres
militaires
en réponse la chine tire deux missiles
balistiques entre l'île de hainan et les
îles paracels zone où la marine
américaines naviguent régulièrement
taiwan constitue un autre terrain de
confrontation
en juillet les états unis approuvent un
contrat de 620 millions de dollars pour
la modernisation de missiles destinés à
sétif à cela s'ajoute le passage
régulier de bateau de guerre américain
par le détroit de taiwan la chine qui
considère taïwan comme partie intégrante
de son territoire est évidemment outre
et washington se montre tout aussi
offensif au sujet de hong kong
en effet l'administration train pas
annulé mi juillet tous les avantages
économiques dont bénéficié ce territoire
en commerçant avec les états unis pékin
adopte une série de sanctions contre des
hauts responsables américains
[Musique]
mais avant de poursuivre voici ce qu'il
faut savoir sur ce différend territorial
qui cristallise les tensions dans la mer
de chine méridionale
c'est le blitz se prolongeant depuis
plusieurs décennies ce contentieux
implique aujourd'hui six états côtiers
qui possèdent chacun sa propre vision
des frontières maritimes
pékin estime détenir 80% de la mer de
chine méridionale
y compris les archipels des paracels et
spratleys ainsi que le récif de
scarborough ses prétentions
territoriales se heurte à celle de ses
voisins les philippines le vietnam la
malaisie ou même brunet et taïwan
ces états ont également des vues sur de
vastes zones près de leur frontière pour
l'instant une partie importante de la
mer est contrôlé par la chine
l'archipel des paracels le récif de
scarborough et une partie des îles
spratleys
celles ci sont divisés entre toutes les
parties du conflit à l'exception de
brunet qui ne contrôle aucune il ainsi
le vietnam contrôler plusieurs îles au
nord ouest de l'archipel
les philippines dans la partie est enfin
à la malaisie dans le côté sud
de son côté taiwan exerce son autorité
sur les îles prat as hell il dit tout à
bas les enjeux de cet espace maritime
contestée sont hautement stratégiques
carrefour d'importantes routes maritimes
commerciales
il relie l'asie orientale à l'océan
indien au moyen-orient et alors côté
ressources
la mer est riche en pétrole et en gaz
mais pas seulement
le manganèse le cobalt le cuivre et même
les diamants font aussi partie de ses
richesses dans la mer de chine
méridionale et tension monte d'un cran
entre pékin et washington fin août un
avion espion américain de traverse la
zone des manoeuvres militaires chinoises
en réponse pékin tir de missile
balistique
vers les zones litigieuses ou la marine
américaine mène de plus en plus souvent
ces opérations baptisées liberté de
navigation en effet washington accusent
les autorités chinoises d'avoir profité
de la pandémie pour faire avancer ses
prétentions territoriales en mer de
chine méridionale
dans les faits plusieurs incidents ont
eu lieu récemment entre la chine et ses
voisins dans les eaux disputées
cependant si la plupart d'entre eux
hésitent à défier ouvertement
pekin les philippines eux menacent
d'appeler à l'aide la marine américaine
en cas de violation flagrante de leur
souveraineté
la situation dans la région risquent de
se complexifier après le renforcement de
la coopération entre les états unis et
taiwan visites de responsables
américains à ventes d'armes et
coopération militaire tout cela irrite
évidemment de plus en plus la chine qui
dénonce les ingérences américaines dans
ses affaires internes
idem en ce qui concerne hong kong en
juillet donald trump prive cette région
spéciale chinoise de ses avantages dans
le commerce avec les états unis pékin
ripostent par des sanctions que
prévoit-elle comment la chine répond
elle à la pression américaine
quelle est la stratégie de washington
pour contrer la influences chinoises en
mer de chine méridionale enfin comment
les états régionaux réagi style à cette
escalade inédit détention pour répondre
à ces questions nous rejoignons fredrik
l'acm directeur du conseil québécois
d'études géopolitiques
monsieur lasserre bonjour bonjour donc
avec la récente montée des tensions dans
la mer de chine méridionale est ce qu'on
peut dire qu'un nouveau conflit
militaire et bientôt possible dans cette
région alors il faut toujours se méfier
des prédictions et de l'affirmation que
la guerre va éclater mais il est certain
que depuis plusieurs années on assiste à
progressivement une montée des tensions
dans la région avec une forte
militarisation des enjeux territoriaux
et maritime dans cet espace maritime
la chine et les autres états de la
région qui ont construit plusieurs bases
militaires sur les récifs l'augmentation
de la fréquence des manoeuvres
militaires des pays d'asie du sud est et
de la chaîne hi fi depuis plusieurs mois
aussi l'augmentation de la fréquence des
manoeuvres de la marine américaine dans
la région
donc la tension augmente beaucoup parce
que ça risque de dégénérer en conflit
personne ne peut le savoir on peut
simplement se poser des questions
effectivement est ce que cette tension
puisque deux de déraper d'aboutir
rapidement à un conflit militaire
si on parle des revendications en mer de
chine méridionale et qui est ce qui est
selon vous ici l'agresseur qui lorgne
sur le gâteau qui ne lui appartient pas
finalement bien malin qui peut répondre
dé manière définitive à cette question
puisque chacun a fourni des arguments
historiques et son interprétation
juridique pour justifier ses
revendications
ce qui est certain c'est que les
archipels en jeu les paracels et les
spratleys contrairement à ce que disent
tous les protagonistes n'ont jamais été
administré directement ni par la chine
ni par le vietnam ni par aucun autre
état dans la région c'était des
archipels était peu fréquenté aux
contrariétés
je suis plutôt par la navigation notre
part on s'aperçoit aussi que les
revendications sur les espaces maritimes
qui sont faits à partir de ces archipels
respecte assez peu l'esprit de la
convention sur le droit de la mer
donc moi je serais d'avis de dire qu' il
ya absolument aucun protagoniste qui
respecte vraiment les principes de la
convention le droit de l'amérique donc
beaucoup de revendications sur sept dans
cette région sont assez peu fondées et
que pensez vous du rôle de l'union
européenne dans toutes les tensions
régionales
peut-on dire que maintenant c'est sûr
bruxelles va soutenir la position
américaine de pression maximale sur la
chine sur encore une fois c'est assez
difficile de l'affirmer
pendant longtemps l'union européenne a
essayé de trouver un équilibre entre
conserver un certain dialogue avec la
chine et en même temps offrir son
soutien au pays de l'asie du sud-est et
conservé aussi son réseau d'alliances
avec le japon avec l'australie avec les
états unis
donc essayer de faire ce jeu
d'équilibriste diplomatique c'est de
plus en plus difficile compte tenu de
l'accroissement des tensions et de
l'affirmation récente de des
revendications de la part de la chine
est ce que ça veut dire pour autant que
l'union européenne va s'aligner sans
réserve sur la position américaine c'est
pas sûr puisque les états unis en ce
moment semble faire le choix de
une confrontation qui encore une fois
n'a pas nécessairement aboutir un
conflit militaire mais en tout cas je me
semble choisir l'option de l'épreuve de
force
est-ce que ça va être une option retenue
par l'union européenne je n'en suis pas
certain mais c'est sûr que la préférence
du pneumatique de l'union européenne va
plutôt du côté des alliés traditionnels
que sont les états unis l'australie et
le japon
merci beaucoup monsieur nasser nous
allons poursuivre notre analyse tout de
suite mais nous vous retrouverons
évidemment en fin d'émission pour plus
de détails sur la question merci le 9
septembre les dix états membres de la
séan tiennent leurs rencontres par
visioconférence la pandémie de kobe de
19 rétablissement de la production
coopération économique l'agenda est plus
que chargé
une attention particulière est portée à
l escalade récente entre la chine et les
états unis en mer de chine méridionale
en bras de fer qui risque d'affecter la
stabilité de la région toute entière
alors que la pandémie due qu'aux vite 19
se poursuit le paysage géopolitique et
géoéconomique régionales y compris en
mer de chine méridionale connaît des
volatilité croissante qui met en danger
la paix et la stabilité entre les deux
superpuissances la tension commence à
monter dès le mois de juillet au début
du mois la chine entame des manoeuvres
militaires autour des îles paracel
revendiqué par le vietnam criant au viol
du droit international washington réagi
en envoyant deux porte-avions les us
ronald reagan et es s nimitz dans les
eaux contestées
cet acte mais la chine en est moi qui le
qualifient de provocation dangereuse
pour la paix régionale
l' escalade prend de l'ampleur fin août
mettant les deux pays au bord d'un
conflit ouvert
le point de départ et le vol d'un avion
espion américain au dessus du golfe de
bois et territoires qui étaient
proclamés par pékin zone d'exclusion
aérienne en raison de nouveaux exercices
militaires le vol perturbe le cours des
manoeuvres et en réponse la chine tire
deux missiles balistiques
ap les tueurs de porte avions vers les
eaux disputées en signal clair adressé
aux états unis
de son côté washington répond le 26 août
en adoptant des sanctions
économiques contre la chine ce sont les
premières sanctions américaines
concernant la politique chinoise en mer
de chine méridionale
vingt-quatre entreprises et personnes
physiques chinois sont désormais ajoutés
à la liste noire américaine
elles sont accusées d'avoir aidé la
chine à renforcer ses positions dans les
zones litigieuses
certaines d'entre elles par exemple ont
joué un rôle clé dans la construction
d'îlots artificiels sur l'archipel
disputé des spratleys l'interdiction est
donc faite aux entreprises américaines
de commercer avec ces entités
aujourd'hui la chine possède sept îlots
artificiels et qui lui servent de vrais
avant-postes en mer de chine méridionale
un atout stratégique qui renforce encore
plus l'avantagé militaire de pékin dans
cette zone selon le département de la
défense américain la marine chinoise et
abrite une partie notable de ses forces
20 sous marins onze des trois heures un
porte-avions et 22 bateaux
lance-missiles à l'échelle nationale la
marine chinoise aurait récemment dépassé
celle des états unis avec près de 350
navires et sous marins
une première mondiale la marine
américaine quand elle possède en tout 2
193 bâtiment qui se concentrent de plus
en plus dans la région indo pacifique
selon l'institut national chinois pour
l'étude de la mer de chine méridionale
60% des navires de guerre américains et
les deux tiers de l'infanterie de marine
ils sont déployés et leur activité est
aussi en hausse durant le premier
semestre 2001 la marine américaine mène
cinq opérations appelées liberté de
navigation sont ces défier les
revendications territoriales de la chine
dans ce bras de fer avec pékin
washington sa chute du soutien de ses
alliés stratégiques dans la région
l'australie et le japon le 7 juillet les
ministres de la défense des trois états
se réunissent par visioconférence afin
de discuter la situation sécuritaire
dans la région
bilan de la rencontre des promesses de
renforcer la coopération militaire et de
défendre la liberté de navigation dans
la mer de chine méridionale
laon
kr est à peine sèche sur la déclaration
que les trois pays mènent des exercices
militaires dans la mer des philippines à
l'est des eaux contestées par pékin les
états unis à leur tour renforce la
pression diplomatique sur la chine qui
l'accusent notamment d'avoir profité de
la pandémie de kobe de 19 pour avancer
aussi ses positions dans les eaux
disputées exemple le 2 avril à un navire
chinois percute un bateau de pêche
vietnamiens et le fait coulé près des
îles paracel disputé par pékin et hanoï
l'accident provoque tout de suite une
virulente critique de la part du vietnam
le 18 avril un nouveau pas vers
l'escaladé franchi la chine annonce la
création de deux nouvelles zones
administratives couvrant les îles
paracels et des spratleys source de
conflits territoriaux avec des états
côtiers en août les philippines
dénoncent l'entrée répétitive des
vaisseaux chinois à l'intérieur de la
zone économique exclusive supposément
pour des activités de recherche
si quelque chose se produit comme une
attaque contre un bâtiment philippins
alors j'appelle washington alors comment
la situation en mer de chine méridionale
at elle évolué au point de devenir un
conflit militaire quels sont les autres
tensions dans la région la réponse après
la pause
[Musique]
de jour en jour les tensions en mer de
chine méridionale s'intensifie exercices
militaires et tir de missile balistique
les deux plus grandes puissances navales
les états unis et la chine
ils défendent chacun leur vision des
frontières une rivalité croissante et
surtout dangereuse qui risque de
complexifier encore plus le conflit
territorial dans ses eaux en cours
pendant plusieurs décennies dans ce
conflit territorial deux états se
disputent la découverte des îles
spratleys et paracels
la chine et le vietnam alors que pékin
parole des pêcheurs chinois fréquentant
la mer de chine du sud depuis l'époque
de l'antiquité un oeil prétend que sont
les vietnamiens qui étaient les premiers
à découvrir les îles au xviie siècle
néanmoins à l'époque coloniale ce sont
les chinois qui dominent cette mère et
cela jusqu'à l'arrivée des colonisateurs
français au milieu du 19e siècle qui
s'empare de la majeure partie du vietnam
et imposent leur contrôle sur presque la
totalité de la mer en repoussant la
chine
la situation change avec le début de la
seconde guerre mondiale la france cède
ses positions et le japon occupe les
archipels spratleys et paracels qui lui
servent de tremplin pour lancer des
attaques contre les pays asiatiques
après la capitulation du japon en 1945
les chinois s'empare du groupe
amphitrite à l'ouest des îles paracels
et de la plus grande des îles spratleys
itunes à bas la guerre civile chinoise
marque un nouveau tournant dans le
conflit
la partie des îles paracel occupé par la
chine républicaine passe sous
l'administration de la république de
chine populaire tandis qu'ils tuent abba
passe sous administration taïwanaise de
l'huile est jetée sur le feu avec le
traité de paix de san francisco de 1951
qui stipule que le japon renonce à sa
souveraineté sur les archipels spratleys
et paracels
sans indiquer à qui ces archipels sont
restitués le vietnam qui contrôlait
jusque là plusieurs îles paracel profite
de l'occasion pour afficher ses droits
historiques sur les deux archipels
c'est à ce moment que les philippines
avancent leurs prétentions territoriales
sur quasi la totalité de l'archipel
spratleys en prétextant que les ils sont
devenus res nullius et en s'appuyant sur
leur proximité géographique dans ce
contentieux les choses bougent en 1974
lorsque la république populaire de chine
profitant de la faiblesse des
sud-vietnamien envahi les îles paracels
contrôlée par le vietnam du sud
en 1975 le vietnam déjà unifiée
protestent et occupe 7 des îles des
spratleys une manoeuvre qui pousse
chacun des états riverains de la mer de
chine du sud à s'emparer deal ou de
recife de l'archipel des spratleys ainsi
la malaisie les philippines le vietnam
et la république populaire de chine se
lance dans la conquête des îles les plus
proches de leurs côtes
en 1992 c'est le tour de brunet
d'afficher ses droits sur une partie de
l'archipel plus précisément il s'agit
des eaux entourant le récif louise a
contrôlé par la malaisie
c'est au même moment que la chine
commence à s'intéresser de plus en plus
à l'archipel des spratleys dès 1992 elle
le revendique en totalité
ajoutons le geste à la parole pékin
occupe le récif eldad et trois ans plus
tard le récif mischief la situation
sécuritaire se détériore entre 1990 et
1995 plus de 100 incidents ont eu lieu
entre les pays côtiers et la chine qui
s'impose de plus en plus comme le maître
de ses eaux
le premier pas vers la détente est
franchie en 2002 les pays de l'asean et
la chine signent en 2002 la déclaration
sur la conduite des parties en mer de
chine méridionale
le document qui les engage à coopérer et
résoudre tout différend de manière
pacifique
néanmoins les incidents continuent en
2012 la chine va jusqu'à prendre le
contrôle du récif de
harbour au contrôle et jusque là par les
philippines en réponse mme annie saisie
en 2013 la cour permanente d'arbitrage
de la haye sur ce dossier trois ans plus
tard cette dernière conclut que la chine
a bien violé les droits souverains des
philippines une décision qui restent
lettre morte
la chine contrôle toujours le récif
disputer dès lors le comptant sur reste
dans l'impasse alors que pékin
entreprend régulièrement des tentatives
d'avancer ses positions dans cette zone
disputée
cette escalade en mer de chine
méridionale n'est d'ailleurs pas une
tendance
isoler ces derniers mois de fortes
tensions jaillissent autour de toutes
les zones sensibles près des côtes
chinoises
c'est le cas notamment de taïwan
considérée par pékin comme sa province
mais le gouverneur dans les faits par un
régime indépendant l'autonomie de l'île
les cependant reconnu par presque aucun
pays du monde y compris les états unis
malgré cela la maison blanche fleurs
toujours plus avec taipei faisant
évidemment grincer les dents à pékin en
août dernier washington envoie taïwan sa
plus importante délégation depuis 1979 à
sa tête le secrétaire américain à la
santé alex adar la présidente de ty guen
et lui signe alors un accord de
coopération
etait-ce pour taquiner pékin ou non mais
également en août des destroyers
américains passent deux fois dans le
détroit de taiwan entre l'île et la
chine continentale
la série de petites provocations de la
maison blanche continue avec l'ouverture
d'un nouveau dialogue économique avec
lille puis avec l'intensification de
vente d'armes américaines à taïwan
tout est cadré par un accord en effet
déjà existants qui avaient été conclus
par ronald reagan
mais dont la mention top secret vient
d'être levé récemment c'est la vente de
18 ans fille lourdes
une modernisation des missiles sol air
et la finalisation du contrat pour 66
chasseurs f 16 qui sont annoncés en
réponse aux manoeuvres diplomatiques
américaines à taïwan la chine n'hésite
pas à rouler des mécaniques ainsi
plusieurs chasseurs chinois frôle
l'espace aérien taiwanais en
août au moment même de la visite
américaine sur l'île deux jours plus
tard pékin révèle avoir mené des
exercices navals et aériens au tour de
taïwan
depuis elle continue ses manoeuvres près
des codes taïwanaise une démonstration
de force mutuelle qui ne débouchent pas
pour le moment sur un conflit ouvert
mais les moyens de pressions
s'accumulent des deux côtés pour sa part
la chine impose des sanctions au
producteur d'armement américain lockheed
martin en juillet et en septembre
d'éventuelles sanctions contre les
responsables et les entreprises
américaines liées à taïwan sont annoncés
par les médias chinois
pourtant c'est aussi sur le plan
diplomatique se joue une autre escale à
régional cette fois ci au tour de hong
kong
ici pas question de remettre en cause la
souveraineté chinoise sur la région mais
c'est la façon dont cette souveraineté
est exercée qui est au centre de la
crise la fameuse nouvelle loi sur la
sécurité est adoptée par la chine en
juillet celles ci concernent hong kong
directement elle étend les pouvoirs de
pékin dans la presqu'île autonome une
affaire interne selon la chine mais une
ingérence pour les états unis
la réaction américaine ne se fait pas
attendre
en réponse washington abroge le régime
économiques préférentielles de hong kong
fini donc les droits de douane réduit et
les exportations de technologies
américaines sensibles de plus désormais
les produits hong kong et devront porter
l'étiquette fabriqués en chine
s'ensuivent les sanctions que washington
prend contre 11 responsables chinois
puis la suspension de trois accords
américain avec hong kong y compris celui
qui porte sur l'extradition
à mon avis hong kong ne pourra plus
faire concurrence au marché libre notre
économie va en profiter puisque nous
venons de perdre concurrents l'action
american et rapidement reprise par ses
alliés l'australie le canada la
nouvelle-zélande et le royaume-uni
suspende eux aussi les traité
d'extradition avec hong kong
l'union européenne elle limite ses
exportations d'armes à la chine est
critique l'attitude de pékin
ces actions remettent en question la
volonté de la chine de respecter ses
engagements internationaux sape la
confiance et affectent les relations
sino européennes
la situation autour de hong kong
inquiète déjà l'onu cependant un autre
conflit régional qui gagne en intensité
passe largement sous les radars de la
communauté internationale au centre des
tensions se trouve à un groupe de petits
kilos en mer de chine orientale
contrôlées par tokyo mais revendiquées
par pékin
les eaux de l'archipel senkaku au japon
où d'ayew en chine sont riches en
poissons et en hydrocarbures
ce différend reste irrésolu depuis les
années 70 or depuis plusieurs mois la
chine accentue encore plus la pression
c'est garde-côtes entre quasi
quotidiennement dans les eaux
territoriales des 100 cas qu il reste
plus de 111 jours de suite c'est le
record depuis la dernière escalade en
la chine affirme qu'il s'agit de
patrouille ordinaire de ses propres eaux
territoriales pour tokyo
c'est bien une incursion sur son
territoire qui se dit prêt à défendre au
centimètre près et pour cela l'armée
japonaise peut compter sur le soutien
américain
les etats-unis sont à 100% inébranlable
dans leur engagement d'aider le
gouvernement du japon dans la situation
autour de l'archipel senkaku cela
signifie 24 heures sur 24 7 jours sur 7
et 365 jours par an un engagement qui ne
semble pas dissuader les navires chinois
qui continuent d'entrer dans la zone
disputée
de son côté le japon évite de répondre
plus fermement de peur de provoquer
pékin mais cette modération va-t-elle
durer
dans une région truffé de conflits
anciens une étincelle peut-elle mettre
le feu aux poudres
pour mieux comprendre l'état des lieux
nous rejoignons à nouveau frédéric
lasserre directeur du conseil québécois
d'études géopolitiques
monsieur lasserre parlons maintenant
d'une autre source de tension dans la
région taïwan
les militaires chinois promettent de
recourir à la force
au cas où la réunification pacifique n'a
pas lieu
est-ce possible selon vous compte tenu
du soutien américain
apportez à lille c'est possible dans la
mesure où effectivement de plus en plus
souvent les dirigeants chinois affirme
que en l'absence de réunification
pacifique donc de volontaires de la part
de taïwan
il y aurait possiblement recours à la
force pendant longtemps la chine n'a
simplement affirmé que toute déclaration
formelle d'indépendance de taiwan se
traduirait par une invasion militaire
aucune réponse d'ordre militaire
maintenant on voit de plus en plus le
discours chinois s'orienter vers sidi si
un certain temps ne tend pas précisé
alors n'y aurait pas d'autre solution
pour la chine que de recourir à la
solution militaire donc se pose la
question est-ce que c'est du bluff
diplomatique ou est-ce que effectivement
la chine à l'intention d'ici ou
permettre que personne ne connaît de
recourir à l'option militaire
ou est-ce que c'est simplement une autre
façon donc une rhétorique pour mettre
davantage de pression sur taïwan
c'est difficile à dire ce qu'on peut
observer c'est qu'effectivement depuis
l'arrivée au pouvoir du shipping et la
montée en puissance économique et
militaire de la chine la chine sans
vraiment une puissance décomplexée c'est
à dire qui affirme sans avec beaucoup
moins de retenue que dans le passé ses
intérêts ses objectifs politiques
économiques et territoriaux dans le
temps la région que par ailleurs si jean
ping ne s'en cache pas il souhaite que
d'ici 2049 c'est à dire le 100e
anniversaire de l'arrivée au pouvoir du
parti communiste chinois la chine va re
devenue une grande puissance
internationale
est ce que ce serait effectivement
l'échéance 2049 pour la réunification et
donc le retour de taiwan au sein de la
mère patrie
si possible encore une fois ce sont des
hypothèses que l'on formule
ce qui est certain c'est que de plus en
plus la chine affirme que d'ici un
certain temps si taiwan ne refuse de la
réintégration au sein de la chine est
bien le gouvernement des cartes grande
chine n'écarte pas l'option militaire
la chine est elle pas finalement un
cercle est seul contre tous sur le long
terme pour hâter le faire face aux
pressions en provenance des états unis
et de ses voisins la chine est
effectivement en butte à une réaction
très vive de la part des etats-unis qui
cherchent à construire un réseau
d'alliances
conte dirigées contre la chine s'est de
plus en plus clair effectivement la
chine n'est pas complètement seul dans
la mesure où elle aussi joue le même jeu
cherche à renforcer des bonnes relations
avec son voisinage immédiat en
particulier en asie du sud-est d utile
est entrée divisée sur l'attitude à
adopter à l'endroit de la chine il ya
des adversaires de la chine en asie du
sud est comme le vietnam de plus en plus
indonésie mais il ya aussi des amis
parfois conjoncturels comme les
philippines depuis l'accès au pouvoir de
liberté il ya des alliés durable comme
le cambodge est d'une certaine façon
c'est le miam à la chine joue aussi
beaucoup sur le proche de son grand
projet de nouvelle route de la soie pour
développer des relations de clientélisme
avec qui république d'asie centrale dans
l'espoir que ensuite au delà de ces
relations économiques et des relations
plus de soutien diplomatique et
politique
donc il ya tout un jeu de rivalité qui
se met en place et par ailleurs la chine
est sur une trajectoire de monter en
puissance économique et politique qui
inquiète beaucoup justement les états
unis inhérents du mal à intégrer le fait
que de plus en plus la chine et l'autre
puissance mondiale qui est pur moment de
clairement pas aussi puissantes que les
états unis mais précisément cette
ascension politique et militaire de la
chine inquiète beaucoup les états unis
et il souhaite contrer cette montée en
puissance
merci beaucoup frédéric lasserre je
rappelle vous êtes directeur du conseil
québécois d'études géopolitiques merci
d'avoir apporté votre éclairage dans
cette émission
cette partie là n'est pas encore
terminée la semaine prochaine une
nouvelle partie vous attend avec
d'autres pions sur l'échiquier mondial
à bientôt sur rt france
[Musique]